[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue pour ce premier rendez vous de la
semaine avec deux observateurs affûté
aiguisé de la vie publique française et
internationale bonsoir nicolas baverez
vous êtes essayiste avocat éditorialiste
au figaro on vous retrouve chaque lundi
dans les pages de notre quotidien a
préféré vous vous intéressez aujourd'hui
à joe biden et à ses travaux d'hercule
le new deal de joe biden et puis je
rappelle votre dernier livre l'alertent
démocratique aux édition de
l'observatoire bonsoir alexandre de vos
soirées où vous êtes journaliste au
figaro responsable des pages débats du
figaro magazine c'est une mission
importante est en charge du figaro vox
aussi est votre livre recomposition le
nouveau monde populiste a été publié aux
éditions du cerf
je propose qu'on commence par un
s'intéresser à un sondage peut l'être un
peu surprenant il a été publié par deux
confrères du parisien
et il montre l'adhésion d'une majorité
de français au concept de passeports
vaccinale alors pour entrer dans le
détail
soixante deux pour cent de nos
concitoyens seraient favorables selon ce
sondage à la mise en place d'un
un passeport qui rendent obligatoire la
vaccination pour ceux qui souhaitent
prendre l'avion et se rendre à
l'étranger à 60% pour les personnes
souhaitant rendre visite à des personnes
vulnérables en maisons de retraite
hôpitaux etc
le taux d'adhésion baisse un peu mais se
maintient quand même à 50% par exemple
pour aller fréquenter les cinémas où les
salles de théâtre quand on connaît le
l'opposition d'à peu près la moitié de
la population au vaccin lui même est ce
que c'est pas un peu surprenante
ce passeport nicolas baverez en tout cas
la position des français parfaitement
raisonnable parce qu'on a un besoin
impératif de ce passeport vaccinale
aujourd'hui même si la vaccination a
commencé
l'om est là bien dit on n'aura pas
d'immunité en 2021 donc cette épidémie
va durer en plus on peut avoir de
nouveaux problèmes de variants on a 10%
de l'économie qui est aujourd'hui à
l'arrêt en france nos pôles d'excellence
ou ressent bah oui l'aéronautique
l'automobile va mal l'aéronautique et en
toute petite forme et surtout hôtellerie
restauration tourisme tout le monde
partie du monde du sport tout le monde
culturel est à l'arrêt ça ça fait dix
pour cent du pib' et ça ça veut dire
qu'il peut pas y avoir de vraie reprise
si on traite pas ce problème d'accès un
autre exemple c'est le transport aérien
le transport aérien
ça promène 58 % des touristes
internationaux et sa promène 35 % du
commerce international en valeur si on
le fait par repartir il aura pas de
vraie reprise et donc pour y arriver il
faut évidemment les vaccins mais il faut
le passeport et les reproches qui lui
sont faits sont des fous reproche on le
critique pour son efficacité son
inefficacité plus tôt mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas un passeport immunitaire
c'est pas parce qu'on a été vaccinée
qu'il faut arrêter de respecter les
règles les règles sanitaires en revanche
ça permet de certifier
premièrement la qualité des vaccins la
qualité des laboratoires et ça c'est
très important c'est une sécurité pour
tous ensuite on dit qu'il est
inégalitaire mais c'est pas vrai parce
que l'égalité c'est même traitement avec
mêmes conditions regardez aujourd'hui
dans les écoles pour les enfants crèches
écoles on demande des vaccins si vous
voulez aller dans un certain nombre de
pays d
ou d'afrique on vous demande d'être
vacciné contre david évidemment mais les
vaccins contrôlable non mais la fièvre
jaune jaune on demande aussi de grands
soirs poil en guyane il faut être
certain des moteurs donc ça c'est
parfaitement normal
du point de vue des libertés c'est un
problème de proportions si vous voulez
l'atteinte aux libertés entre si on doit
ce avoir encore un confinement on va
avoir des confinement à répétition on
organise la mort économique de secteurs
entiers de l'économie
les jeunes sont quand même coupés de
leurs études de leurs amis de la
possibilité de rentrer sur le marché du
travail et d'un point de vue moral là
aussi je pense que jacques sacré au
contraire une incitation pour les gens à
se faire vacciner
et deuxièmement pour les gouvernements à
accélérer la vaccination est donc ce
passeport vaccinale est à mon avis une
excellente chose et dernière remarque ça
c'est une invention très française
puisque je rappelle que c'est la france
qui a inventé le passeport sous louis
xiv pour le mercantilisme et et pour les
sauf-conduit et que c'est la france qui
a inventé le vaccin avec pascal en 1881
donc et surtout notre pays si vous
voulez si un pays qui en a besoin pour
repartir c'est l'autre donc prenons la
tête du combat font le passé alors on
est peut-être est-ce que votre vibrant
plaidoyer géré m a convaincu le
gouvernement
il y avait un peu de boulot mon problème
c'est de convaincre alexandre oui avant
d'écouter les gens vraiment important
c'est à dire à la fin de juin pourquoi
dès que tu es un membre du gouvernement
non mais ça va sûrement vous permettre
de réagir cher à l'exemple et mambo du
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
il était hier sur france info élu en
fait il est pas très chaud moi je veux
dire je nous sommes très réticents à
cette idée
de quoi parle-t-on exactement si on dit
un passeport un papier un document qui
vous autorise en l'occurrence par
exemple à voyager en europe
je crois que c'est un débat qui est très
prématuré
c'est un débat qui aujourd'hui je crois
n'a pas lieu d'être et je crois qu'il
serait choquant de dire alors qu'on
débute encore partout cette campagne de
vaccination en europe qui a un passeport
avec des droits plus important pour
certains que pour d'autres ce n'est pas
notre conception de la protection et de
l'accès au vaccin
alex non mais je dois dire que je suis
assez d'accord avec le gouvernement pour
une fois qu'elle serait quand même des
des champions du monde à inventer un
autre document administratif d'une
nouvelle attestation alors même qu'on
n'a pas de valeur car moi je pense que
tout simplement ce débat pour l'instant
ne ne se pose pas au rythme on va pour
avoir une vaccination collectifs
il va falloir des années on n'est pas
pour le moment en mesure de déployer une
action de vaccination de masse donc à
partir du moment où tout le monde ne
peut pas être vacciné je vois pas
pourquoi on exigera un passeport vaxy
d'un mois j'ai 34 ans a priori je suis
pas prioritaire pour me faire vacciner
une forme
voilà je suis en pleine forme je vois
pas pourquoi je ne pourrais plus enfin
voyager je paierai le le fait que la
france finalement n'a pas réussi à
s'organiser pour déployer la vaccination
commençons par faire les choses dans
l'ordre à mon avis d'autant plus que je
pense qu'on n'arrivera jamais à une
vaccination collective totale et qu'en
plus elle et elle n'est pas forcément
utile si on avait arrivé à vacciner les
20 millions de personnes concernées ce
serait déjà pas mal
ça éviterait les personnes susceptibles
d'hospitalisation ça éviterait
l'engorgement des hôpital et on pourrait
sortir de cette crise avec un un virus
certes qui circulent mais on vivrait à
le avec le virus qui serait déjà pas si
mal donc voilà commençons par là
admettons que dans un futur très
lointain et hypothétique tout le monde
soit vacciné pourquoi pas créer ce
passeport mais là je trouve que si le
gouvernement se lancer là dedans ce
serait vraiment quelque part un peu
risible parce que il a su anticiper sur
rien sur les frontières on nous explique
un creux virus n'a pas besoin de
passeport donc au stade le seul pays à
ne pas fermer les frontières
alors on commence à le faire mais ne pas
fermer les frontières mais à distribuer
encore des passeports et des
attestations en attaque je pense que
voilà lancé ce débat maintenant ne peut
que embrouilles et tout le reste que le
gouvernement se concentre pour avoir une
bonne logistique pour vacciner non pas
pour l'ordre et le calme comme le dit
l'encas 15 mai le plus vite possible
tous ceux qui le souhaitent
vous allez voir réagir nicolas mais je
voudrais vous dire que nos internautes
sont aussi partagées que vous sur ce
plateau
êtes vous favorable à l'instauration
d'un passeport vaccinale pour lutter
contre la coved 19
et bien c'est non mais à 52% donc c'est
quand même assez serré
voici quelques arguments quelques points
de vue de nos chers internautes celui de
winter muse sur youtube qui lui est pour
au moins pour les commerçants qui
pourront peut-être réouvrir plus vite
grâce à ça certes ils vont réouvrir
avons surtout il faut lire ils vont pas
réouvrir dans trois ans faut arrêter le
délire
nicole 06 d'accord pour un passeport
pour prendre un avion mais pour la vie
de tous les jours c'est liberticide
kriss kross on n'est même pas fichu de
vacciner donc le passeport vaccinale et
de la science fiction
et puis chardons bleus qui de toute
évidence c'est pas encore fait
complètement son opinion j'ai un avis
partagé tout dépend des conditions de
mise en place
nicolas baverez c'est vrai que vous
n'allez pas empêché ce pauvre alexandre
d'aller passer ses vacances à l'île
maurice sous pression alors pour prendre
l'avion de toute manière je pense que il
n'aura pas le choix c'est à dire que de
toute manière lee atea travail sur les
que de toute manière les compagnies
aériennes demanderont les filaments
demanderont sauf en france où s'étaient
pas demandé il ya ça suffit pas alors
mais alors d'abord si on veut être faire
un peu d'humour un nombre donné on peut
dire si on prend le gouvernement
ça c'est de l'ordre des probabilités
mais je vous rappelle que le
gouvernement était réticent contre les
masques qui s'est trompé il était
réticent contre les tests il s'est
trompé il était réticent sur le vaccin
il s'est trompé il est réticent sur le
passeport vaccinale il ya quand même une
bonne chose qu'ils se trompent de
manière on n'y ait pas de manière plus
sérieuse sur les alors il ya deux choses
qui sont importantes d'abord c'est pas
un passeport pour la vie quotidienne on
va évidemment pas demander des gens
passeport vaccinale pour aller acheter
une baguette en revanche qui est vitale
et notamment pour la france est la
première destination touristique
on a perdu 61 milliards d'euros 3 points
de pib uniquement sur le tourisme l'an
dernier et donc si on veut rouvrir nos
hôtels de luxe
si on veut rouvrir des autres des
restaurants si on veut rouvrir tout ceci
il faut que les gens puissent voyager et
si les gens doivent voyager il ne
voyageront ils ne pourront être
accueillis par exemple aussi dans des
salles de spectacle que si les
conditions sanitaires sont assurés donc
on en a un besoin vital
et c'est particulièrement important pour
les jeunes parce qu'il ya quand même
toute une partie de gens qui travaillent
dans ces secteurs et qu'ils vont perdre
tout simplement le
l'outil de travail mais la possibilité
de la possibilité de travailler alors
les modalités sont évidemment très
importante on l'a dit là c'est là où
l'europe est utile ça n'a pas de sens on
va pas faire un passeport français dans
son coin
il est évidemment il faut que ce soit un
système européen
les grecs par exemple ans de mandat et
la deuxième est la deuxième chose c'est
et ils ont bien raison mais les grecs
parce que les grecs ils sont quand même
ben oui mais comme ou encore plus que
nous si je puis dire en termes de
pourcentage du pipe mais nous on a plus
de monde à accueillir
et là évidemment il faut faire attention
aux modalités et notamment
il faut que qui a une protection des
données personnelles
à mon avis il faudrait que les données
ses bases de données soit abrité en
dehors du cadre des gouvernements ce qui
est technologiquement est tout à fait
possible et avoir un système qui soit
évidemment compatible avec la la
protection des avec la protection des
droits
mais je le répète c'est très important
aussi pourquoi parce que c'est la
meilleur moyen de lutter contre les faux
certificats on va avoir des faux vaccins
on va avoir des faux certificats
on va voir et si vous voulez ça va être
un moyen de garantir de lutter contre
les contrefaçons
les faussaires et tous les gens qui vont
vendre du faux certificats et du faux
vaccins sur internet
je vais vous dire je trouve ce débat
passionnant parce que je vous écoute
l'un puis l'autre et je change d'avis
encore une fois comme vous prenez la
part alors peut-être que vous allez
faire encore changer d'avis non j'écoute
aussi ce qui est dit aimer mais ça c'est
dans un futur hypothétique le problème
c'est qu'on en est c'est là où ça paraît
paradoxal le gouvernement vient de se
réveiller seulement maintenant pour dire
demander un test pcr à tout un tas de
pays en rendez vous compte que les fonds
tient a été ouverte pour pour la
majorité a été ouverte je parle même pas
d'ouverture bien sûr qu'elle est over
mais il n'y avait même pas de contrôles
aux aéroports pour ceux qui qui arrivait
de l'étranger donc avant de mettre en
place le passeport vaccinale fera
peut-être une efficacité propos du reste
du récit on arrive
dans tous les pays n'ont pas éradiquer
ces maladies pasqua pour les rails
d'ariel crap 1 c'est comme la grippe ça
va revenir ce différentes formes
chaque année mes affaires qu'elles
soient maîtrisable sera peut-être pas
non plus totalement inutile d'avoir
d'avoir ce passeport là donc on verra
mais je pense que lancer le débat du
passeport au moment où on a pas de
vaccin ça risque de crisper l'opinion
plutôt qu'autre chose
donc deux choses premièrement évidemment
qu'il faut des contrôles aux frontières
d'ailleurs y compris pour contrôler ce
passeport si un jour il doit voir le
joueur deuxièmement et c'est vrai que
c'est une anomalie complète de la france
on n'a jamais fait de contrôle aux
frontières on n'a jamais fait
d'isolement mais ça c'est la folie du
gouvernement français c'est pas pour ça
qu'il faut pas relancer l'activité chez
nous ensuite on a complètement foiré le
début de la campagne de vaccination mais
là encore ce n'est pas parce qu'on s'est
raté sur la campagne de vaccination qui
font se rater sur le passeport vaccinale
est en danger c'est absolument vrai
c'est que si on veut mettre en place ce
passeport
ça veut dire qu'en tout cas dans le
cadre européen
il faut avoir un accès universel rapide
et gratuit au vaccin oms les accords bon
et bien voilà vous chers internautes de
vous faire votre avis parlons maintenant
de ce qui a peut-être été les
fiançailles les plus courtes de
l'histoire récente du capitalisme la
semaine dernière un groupe canadien
québécois pour être précis qui répond au
joli nom de couche-tard a fait des
approches à carrefour le leader français
de la grande distribution en vie en vue
d'un rapprochement probablement d'un
rachat mais c'était pas une op à en
bonne et due forme
carrefour s'est montrés intéressés mais
le gouvernement
pas du tout c'est hors de question a dit
bruno le maire c'est non pourquoi bien
parce que c'est ce serait la
souveraineté alimentaire de la france
qui aurait été remise en cause selon le
ministre de l'économie qui expliquait
ainsi que les français auraient pu se
retrouver sans avoir de pâtes ou de riz
dans les magasins carrefour
alors peut-être que dans ces cas là les
gens a pu aller chez lidl sauf que lidl
cd allemande peut-être que les allemands
aussi aurait voulu nous affamer
en tout cas ça ne se fera pas ce mariage
écouter quelqu'un qui sont réjouies qui
est un patron au plus tôt un ancien
patron mais d'un genre c'est vrai un peu
particulier il s'agit de louis gallois à
l'ancien président du conseil de csa
est-ce que carrefour a besoin de ça
carrefour actuellement ne semble pas
avoir besoin de devenir une partie de
couche tard
moi je trouve que à partir de ce moment
là les arguments d'indépendance
alimentaire de souveraineté alimentaire
banque en jeu pourquoi harper du terme
sont des arguments parfaitement
recevable et donc je ne menace urgent
pas contre une décision que l'on voit
d'ailleurs ont beaucoup de pays
voilà les gallois qui était le président
du conseil de surveillance de psa
c'est à dire le groupe peugeot citroën
alexandre de vécu quand vous entendez le
mot souveraineté vous vous réjouissez
non mais quand même vous l'avais cru bon
de le maire quand il a dit que ce groupe
couche-tard aurait pu essayer d' affamer
les français non je pense que je vais
vous dire de vous surprendre je pense
que l'argument de la souveraineté
alimentaire n'est pas le bon mais c'est
un argument juridique parce que la loi
le permet pour pour empêcher ce genre de
sujet je pense qu'il ya les des secteurs
beaucoup plus stratégique éclat le
gouvernement un peu incohérent il a
autorisé le rachat d'alstom d'alcatel de
thé slip de l'aéroport de toulouse par
des chinois issa laye s'apprêtait à
vendre à adp de la fage
donc voilà il ya une part d'inconnu ans
dans le gouvernement et de posture
politique quand il parle de souveraineté
alimentaire incohérences ou c'est une
conversion je pense que l'euro
attachement à la souveraineté est assez
superficiel mais que bruno le maire fait
partie de ceux qui ont un peu de sens
politique de
au sein du gouvernement et que et qu'il
a il a enfourché le créneau d'ailleurs
comme à emmanuel mal qu'on qu'un peu de
sens politique aussi fait dans la
souveraineté rhétorique mais si si si
une conversion profonde au souverainisme
économique du gouvernement français je
n'y crois pas maintenant est-ce qu'il
fallait autoriser ou pas cette vente je
compte posco quand même il faut soutenir
le gouvernement sur le fait qu'il là
qu'il l'a qui l'a empêché parce qu'ils
avaient des lois de raison même si c'est
pas effectivement la sécurité
alimentaire des français carrefour et la
troisième entreprise du cac 40 en
chiffre d'affaires
la deuxième par celui qui a réalisé en
france et on voyait effectivement louis
gallois bien a bien résumé quel est
l'intérêt à part l'intérêt immédiat à
court terme pour les actionnaires de ce
rachat
on n'en voyait pas beaucoup couche-tard
à une rentabilité plus grande que celle
de carrefour donc on suppose qu'ils
auraient eu c'est ça a été dit
d'ailleurs sans doute des
restructurations donc en termes d'emploi
ce n'était pas forcément une bonne chose
et de manière générale on a vu que tout
ce qui avait été fusions acquisitions
ces dernières années c'est terminé
quasiment dans 100% des cas on pourra
citer voilà pechiney arcelor lafarge
alcatel par une disparition du groupe ou
une vente à la découpe d'ailleurs tous
les éditorialistes qui nous d'économies
qui nous explique à chaque fois que
c'est la bonne décision etc ne
reviennent pas une fois que le groupe a
disparu pour nous dire qu'ils se sont
trompés
donc je pense que voilà le gouvernement
est dans son rôle c'est pas une question
de sécurité alimentaire mais c'est une
question de bon sens tout simplement
on rappelle que carrefour c'est le
premier employeur privé en france
puisqu'il ya cent mille personnes qui
travaillent pour ce groupe de grande
distribution dans l'hexagone 100 milles
sur un total de 300 milles avant de vous
passer la parole nicolas baverez je vous
indique cette dernière déclaration du
pdg de couche tard brian à nash qui
redit son intérêt pour une transaction
avec carrefour
nous aimerions faire cette transaction
at il déclaré donc peut-être que
ça n'est que partie remise peut-être
après les présidentielles qui êtes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce que
vous êtes tombé de votre chaise quand
vous avez entendu bruno le maire dira
non un rapprochement entre de deux
entreprises privées non stratégiques
surtout sait les conditions dans
lesquelles ce nom a été prononcé qui
sont problématiques parce que comme
comme il a été dit c'est pas une
question de souveraineté alimentaire
carrefour fait de la distribution vous
l'avez rappelé on a des groupes
allemands qui font de la distribution
lidl d'autres et qui participe la
souveraineté alimentaire elle se joue
sur la production et on voit très bien
la confusion complète des des genres et
la deuxième chose c'est que la forme est
très choquant puisque le ministère des
finances n'a pas pris la peine d'étudier
le dossier
le ministre n'a même pas vu les
responsables en question il les a reçus
après à peine 20 minutes il n'a même pas
écouté quel était le projet et il a dit
non donc il a dit non pour sur une
posture qui effectivement une posture
tout à fait politique et qui ne
correspond pas aux intérêts des
entreprises pourquoi parce que quand
louis gallois dit que carrefour n'a pas
besoin mais il se trompe complètement le
problème de la distribution
il s'appelle amazon et alibaba donc ces
entreprises si elles veulent survivre
elles ont besoin de milliards à investir
pour tenir face à ces géants et
renouveler complètement leur modèle
économique
et on voit que carrefour seule n'en a
pas les moyens puisque notamment parmi
les actionnaires il ya la famille qui
possèdent les galeries lafayette et qui
elle-même souhaite mettre de l'argent
pour moderniser avant tout les galeries
lafayette et quand on regarde ce qui se
passe dans la distribution
d'abord c'est des emplois qui sont une
activité et des emplois qui sont non
délocalisables
parce que le commerce alimentaire y
compris dans la grande distribution
vous n'allez pas servir depuis l'irlande
ou la pologne
les consommateurs français en matière de
commerce alimentaire est en fait donc il
n'y avait pas de problème d'emploi
précisément parce que couche-tard et
canadiens et qu' il fait tout autre
chose qu'est ce qui va se passer face à
lille
et amazon c'est que ce qu'on a commencé
à voir il va y avoir une concentration
dans la grande distribution et cette
concentration là comme elle va se faire
un acteur français
là pour le coup vous allez détruire
beaucoup d'encre mais et c'est la
réalité de ce qui va se passer donc vous
voyez que tout tout est absurde dans
cette position est par ailleurs c'est
vrai que si la le donner dernière chose
je rappelle que donc côté public on à
120% du pipe de dettes publiques côté
entreprises françaises on à 140% du pipe
de dette privée et donc si vous voulez
en ce moment car la boîte une entreprise
endettée
non mais la priorité c'est de ramener du
capital dans ce pays pour pouvoir
modernisés quand on regarde et il y
avait encore un rapport sur la
productivité
on voit que le retard technologique de
la france post épidémie il a explosé et
donc et dans les qualifications et dans
les investis dans l'appareil productif
donc aujourd'hui il nous faut ramener du
capital et pouvoir moderniser ce pays
ensuite si vous voulez que très
franchement et à regarder d'ailleurs
carrefour est au brésil
les boys a pas un brésilien qui a eu
l'idée absurde de dire que la
souveraineté alimentaire du brésil était
menacé parce que carrefour a été un
grand acteur de la distribution
évidemment qu'ils sont contents d'avoir
carrefour et ils ont bien raison parce
que c'est un avantage
il ya aussi alexandre eux il ya les
entreprises françaises qui l'ont
rachetée par des groupes étrangers vous
insistiez la liste au début de votre
intervention mais vous avez le contraire
et mais c'est surtout dans l'industrie
voilà est ce qui est incroyable c'est
que par exemple je crois que d'un jour à
l'autre la la le rachat de bombardier
qui est un le constructeur de trains
canadien justement par le français
alstom est sur le point d'être
officialisé la passe
les lorrains bien ils vont dire on va la
prochaine fois quand un industriel
français veut vous racheter une boîte
canadien on dira non et tout le monde va
se refermer non non ça marche pas comme
ça ça pesait pas assez caricatural et
parfois c'est intéressant parfois ce
n'est pas intéressant nicolas baverez
disaient qu'ils n'auraient pas de
conséquences pour l'emploi je suis super
sûr on observe déjà que de plus en plus
de grandes distributions enfin de deux
grandes surfaces sans caissière c'était
on n'a pas besoin que vous me direz mais
ça c'est au pas les canadiens vous êtes
ici pas les canadiens n'a pas besoin de
couche-tard là dessus mais mais
mais je pense que la fusion la con
conduire est peut-être couche tard qui
au canada à s intéresser mois à
carrefour aucun couche tard je suis pas
sûr vu les précédents que ce soit
quelque chose d'efficace d'un point de
vue économique à un point sur lequel je
veux bien vous rejoindre c'est qu'il ya
une sous capitalisation sans doute des
entreprises françaises de l'industrie
française etc et qui à mon avis il faut
essayer de réduire ce problème de sous
capitalisation en encourageant les gens
à investir mais je suis pas sûr que ça
doivent passer à chaque fois par mail à
des fins un phénomène de concentration
je vais prendre l'exemple et se paye
très cher mais qui s'est payé très cher
je suis d'accord pour des groupes
beaucoup plus stratégique que nous pour
éclairer le débat
la loi de contrôle sur les
investissements étrangers elle a été
récemment appliqué à un cas qui pour le
coup est un très bon cap qui est
photonis c'est là les appareils de
vision nocturne ou là on avait un vrai
problème
d'abord de création d'un monopole
mondial par en tout cas dans le monde
occidental par les états unis est un
vrai problème de fuite technologie hors
d'eau hors de france alors que ces
technologies sont vitales pour
l'aéronautique pour nos armées pour
toute une série de six tours stratégique
donc là qu'on se soit opposé à la vente
ça me pose aucun problème là c'est fondé
dans le cas de carrefour
on a même payé mais là ça a été étudiée
avant par ailleurs de donner la réponse
est on a donné la bonne réponse là on
donne une mauvaise réponse à un problème
qu'on n'a pas étudié
c'est vraiment dommage nos internautes
sont plutôt en accord avec alexandre
l'échec du rachat de carrefour par le
groupe canadien couche tard est il une
bonne nouvelle vous répondez oui à 63%
par ailleurs cela envoie un signal d'un
gouvernement qui n'hésite pas à
intervenir quand il le faut et il est au
logiquement c'était un tabou en fait
donc ce qui est intéressant là c'est que
bruno le maire vient de briser un tabou
je pense que c'est parce qu'on est très
proche de la présidentielle qu'il fait
ça mais vos tabou après tabou
on avait fait un mort photo nice et pour
le coup dans de bonnes conditions donc
nos internautes quand distille le maire
tape du poing sur la table mais il est
totalement inefficace nous dit nicole 06
peut-être sur d'autres sujets mais en
tout cas sur seulement il a été écouté
babineau considère que l'argument de
bruno le maire sur le fond est un peu
faible
dommage de fermer la porte avec autant
de fébrilité nous dit il et puis
frédéric sur youtube le gouvernement
français fait de l'ingérence je ne
comprends pas grand chose à l'économie
kriss kross sur lefigaro.fr qui remarque
avec les bornes automatiques carrefour a
déjà supprimé pas mal d'emplois
et puis hugo hugo sur youtube qui
s'inquiète si discussions de rachat il
ya alors cela veut dire que la situation
n'est pas bonne je suis quand même
inquiet je voudrais revenir alexandre
sur votre argument disant il faut
inciter les gens effectivement les
entreprises françaises sont concentrées
capitaliser donc il faut investir dedans
alors imaginons que je suis un français
un peu d'argent de côté j'écoute
alexandre de vécu ou est-ce que je suis
attachée à mon pays et donc j'ai acheté
les actions carrefour réactions parfois
elle se traîne à 14 euros depuis des
années et là arrive
l'occasion comme les rachète à 21 euros
c'était la valorisation prévu voir les
canadiens plus 40% il faut il se sera
pas possible il faut trouver un
équilibre entre la dictature de
l'actionnaire parce que je pense que le
l'actionnariat court terme conduit
parfois à faire de mauvais choix
stratégique à long terme et c'est vrai
que peut-être que vous y gagnerez en
tant qu'actionnaire à court terme mais
si le groupe se casse la figure
dans quelques années vous serez ruine et
donc c'est pas c'est pas forcément
logique donc il faut qu'il faut trouver
un équilibre entre les deux peut-être
trouver des mesures fiscales forte pour
inciter les gens à investir dans les
entreprises à mon avis la solution elle
est plutôt là que de favoriser voilà et
c'est ce qu'on fait en fait de favoriser
des ddd choix à court terme et ça se
paye par la disparition des entreprises
en france donnant je dois juste dire
c'est que la première raison de cette
opération
ce ne sont pas les actionnaires certes
il gagnerait de l'argent par rapport au
cours actuel
mais la vraie raison c'est la survie de
carrefour carrefour est confronté à deux
révolutions gigantesque le numérique et
le passage sur le bio pour l'alimentaire
la nouvelle direction a commencé à faire
le pas mais elle ne dispose pas des
fonds qui sont nécessaires pour arriver
à faire ces transformations
sachant que les actionnaires actuels ne
vont certainement pas remettre de
l'argent dans la société pour le pour le
faire donc l'arrivée c'est vrai que
l'arrivée de couche tard que c'était la
capacité de dégager ses ressources pour
faire face à celle est assez grande
révolution donc en c'est sale c'est sur
le modèle économique et la modernisation
de l'entreprise que ces décès
c'est pas simplement pour que les
actionnaires voit l'action qui était
effectivement à 13 ou 14 euros passé à
16 ou 18 euros c'est vraiment la survie
de l'entreprise
la modernisation et l'adaptation est là
où je rejoins alexandre c'est que c'est
celle là où cette histoire est
intéressante au delà d d d d avatar et
de l'irrationalité des décisions
ministérielles qui sont tout entiers a
guidé par la communication et jamais par
le bien commun mais ce qui est important
c'est que le problème de carrefour
c'est le problème de toute notre
économie c'est-à-dire que nous sommes
face à des révolutions gigantesque
l'épidémie a bien montré les fragilités
de nos entreprises
on les a gavé de près elles n'ont pas de
fonds propres et elles vont devoir faire
face aux séquelles de l'épidémie à la
révolution numérique et à la transition
écologique et essai ce problème qu'il
faut traiter et ça au moins si le cas de
carrefour permettait de le poser ce
problème et d'essayer de trouver par
exemple ce qui est dans la continuité de
ce qui était suggéré au lieu de
continuer à gaver les entreprises de
près de commencer à essayer de trouver
des dispositifs pour les renforcer en
fonds propres au moins le jaillir les
mésaventures de carrefour servirait au
moins est totalement l'intérêt du pays
on est totalement d'accord avec ça il ya
un poids aussi qui est intéressant quand
même à se soulever
pourquoi couche-tard finalement est
beaucoup plus rentable aujourd'hui que
carrefour c'est aussi parce que les
peut-être la crise de 2008 a été mieux
gérer dans les pays nord américains avec
finalement des plans de relance et des
politiques monétaires qui créent et puis
s'en moque des bulles mais qui ont
permis de soutenir peut-être l'économie
beaucoup plus que on l'a fait en europe
ce qui est tout à fait juste c'est que
faut jamais oublier qu'en europe on a eu
la crise de mon lait de la
mondialisation plus la crise de l'eau de
l'euro donc merci on a eu là on a eu une
double lame et est très très très très
sévères merci beaucoup à tous les deux
pour vos points de vue le temps plus
passionnant qu'ils étaient divergents
sur ces deux sujets intéressants notre
vie sanitaires et économiques que
bonsoir à tous merci d'avoir suivi point
de vue et rendez vous demain à la même
heure au même endroit sur figaro live
[Musique]